didn't you think that nick jonas was
married to deepak chopra's daughter am i
the only one who thought that i felt so
embarrassed
rosie o'donnell apologized to priyanka
chopra following an awkward encounter
over the weekend the former talk show
host took the tick tock to share details
about the faux pas and um
i just want to apologize to her and to
everyone who thought that it was really
inappropriate of me sorry you know
sometimes i [ __ ] up
also present for the moment priyanka's
husband nick jonas friend of rosie's
friend dresher as well as her son blake
everybody it's me rosie o'donnell and i
just embarrassed my son and his
girlfriend teresa because seated next to
us at malibu at nobu
was nick jonas and his wife
someone chopra
which i always assumed was deepak
jopra's daughter as rosie explained
priyanka quickly corrected her false
assumption
so when i said
hi nick jonas you were great in kingdom
and hi i know your dad she goes you do
who's my dad i'm like deepak
she's like no
and chopra is a common name i was like
[Music]
i felt so embarrassed priyanka's actual
father aisha chopra died in 2013
following a long battle with cancer my
dad was not just my biggest champion but
like my biggest cheerleader so you know
it's like the feeling of like
unconditional
support forever rosie later posted
another message to tick tock offering a
formal apology priyanka i hope i'm
pronouncing that right and um
i just want to apologize to her and to
everyone who thought that it was really
inappropriate of me sorry you know
sometimes i [ __ ] up
i didn't know boo priyanka has yet to
publicly respond to this apology
according to the comments a lot of
people thought that too
rosie also responded to reactions she
saw on social media she's apparently a
very well-known actress and more famous
than him people were saying
so i'm sure it felt weird to her to
begin with people thought that
she was rude she wasn't rude it was just
awkward you know
i mean
i'm sure she gets sick of that i'm sure
i'm not the only one
this follows new details et learned
about the high-profile couple who
recently became first-time parents via
surrogate i have a lot of faith in who
my husband is and i know i have a lot of
faith in the rock that he is for our
family and you know that's such a great
feeling to be able to like lean on
someone and know that they got you and
the source told et last month priyanka
is very maternal and has wanted to be a
mother for a long time the source adds
they are both so happy and settling into
parenthood nicely
[Music]